hi everybody i'm lauren zima on Monday
night's the Bachelorette finale we saw
one of the most emotional moments in the
franchise's history when Peter Krause
and Rachel Lindsay said goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
things did not get much better when the
two saw each other for the first time in
months live on the finale to see that
it's brought me all back into it
full go I'm shaking like a leaf right
now it's done
terrified it's it's interesting for me
because like watching that back it makes
it seem like the whole focal point on us
was the fact that you wouldn't propose
my emotion that you see it comes from
what I had experienced in my prior
relationship before so what do you guys
think it seems like Rachel does not want
Peter to be the next Bachelor based on
this quote I just don't think like this
this world this process this journey
this this show like I just don't think
like it's for you like you need more
time you need to like see things through
but do you see it happening let me know
over on Twitter
[Music]
you